look at that dialogue now honey may I
know how was the day today I forgot to
ask you about it it was good how was
your day sweetheart they seem pretty
cute don't they especially when you find
out that the grandma is actually a
bearded man and another man wants to
scam her right now it seems like I'm
sending the money no no honey you are
not sending to anyone else you don't
have to be worry about it okay the
scammer payback got a call from a
Richard Johnson or Amazon refund scammer
just be there for a moment give me 1
minute please hny you are really a very
funny you can already start worrying
about our grandma's new boyfriend
Richard but when our granny berther is
trying to solve the problem with money
drain and not succumb to the
$999 operation her Alter Ego scammer
payback has already got into the
scammer's computer deleted 3,000 to
4,000 files from the computer and
revealed their location be like
Bera